hello everyone and welcome to a game
from the European Club Cup it's around
five and it's again from board five so
it's six players against six players and
it's really an amazing game and at the
moment I'm making this video we are ten
excellent subscribers short of reaching
the milestone of half a million
subscribers so you know one of you could
be that person that takes this channel
to the next milestone just saying and
also I you're gonna think I chose this
game because it involves the French
defense but that's really not the case I
saw this tweet by neppo he tweeted he
said just wow and he showed the position
from this game and of course I was very
intrigued and decided that I'm gonna
check up on this game and tomorrow when
I woke up I was like everyone was
tweeting about it and for good reasons
and also you can see the ratings here so
I'd install a man he's an international
master from Azerbaijan a key one this
year he won the under 14 World Youth
Championship so very strong player
obviously but he faces the freshest
highest rated player even charged so
without further ado let's check it out
even opens with E for as usually does we
have E six d4 and d5 the French defense
is on the board will Knight to c3 and
Bishop to b4 the vinegar variation of
the French 'if I've advancing the pawn
and c5 now so if you've ever studied the
venerable variation of the French this
is also all very standard stuff a three
characters B captures and now Queen to
c7 or Knight to e7 are the most popular
moves here but Queen to a5 is is also a
it's a move that that's also played but
not not as much as the previous two so
okay Bishop to b2 we have Queen to a4
now putting pressure on the d4 pawn and
of course preventing the Queen from
being developed as the seed upon would
also be under attack but Queen to g4
nonetheless and this is again all
standard stuff if Queen captures then
you can capture on g7 not a problem kink
the f8 yet another standard maneuver for
any good French player and I've reached
this position several times in my
classical games and I don't think I
ever knew what I should play here so
after king 2f8 I just thought okay let's
just continue to get maybe maybe the
seat upon should be sacrificed maybe
something I think I actually play King
to be won in some games maybe even
Bishop to d3 allowed c4 and then
sacrifice the c2 pawn but whatever even
plays Queen to d2 and well we all we all
learn something here so Queen returns
and the reason I probably never thought
of this is because I don't like like
bringing my pieces back to where they
came from and I don't know what the idea
of Queen 31 is but even will show what
the idea is Knight to e7 black continues
development and now Queen to b1
pressuring the b7 pawn so you cannot
develop the bishop but also Queen to b3
is an idea where you will push back the
black Queen or if black wants the trade
then you will fix your pawn structure so
that's that's the plan Queens you for
back to d1 to be one very very nice so
c4 not allowing that and the now comes
Knight to e2 again continuing
development we have Nightbeat c6 and
here there is a game that reached this
exact same position also a creation
player and modern poets are reached it
against even farrago in 2013 in
Bundesliga overnight to g3 was played in
that game ended in the draw but even
goes Knight to f4 here and it is as a
move 12 that we have a completely new
game so let's see how how young I did
deals with the position he plays b6 and
now he can develop the light square
Bishop the b7 pawn will no longer be a
target after the bishop moves and not
Knight to h5 so this is a very concrete
attacking idea
we have Bishop to d7 now the bishop can
be developed and now Queen to c1 already
with some very dangerous threats for
example if if black isn't careful in
black plays will a slow move then just
Knight captures on g7 is deadly you
cannot capture the night if you capture
it you're just getting mated Bishop to
h6 check in g8 Queen g5 check Knight g6
and Queen to f6 ends in mate after Queen
to g7 there's no way to prevent this so
after Queen to see one we have rook to
g8 of course not allowing even to
sacrifice the night on g8 and here comes
H 4 again preparing to bring yet another
attacker into the game
we have kinked yet this is what you have
to be willing to do if you're playing
the French you have to go King a fade
back to Eden back to didn't back to c7
to hide your King to safety
we have rook to h3 King to d8 and now
rook to f3 pressuring the f7 pawn and
now kinked c7 asking white are are you
may be interested in capturing the pawn
but it doesn't seem all that great
because if you actually do capture the
pawn rook captures an f7 bishop that it
could be it could be very annoying then
the knight here will be under attack so
you don't really win anything
so after king c7 just g3 preparing to
bring the bishop into the game and now
rook 8 f8 now defending the pawn we have
Bishop to h3 again developing and the
bishop - eh now we have knight back the
f4 form for a moment there aren't any
tricks here but who knows at some point
Bishop captures an e6 might be an idea a
bushel captures Knight captures would
check you pick up the roof and f8 so it
could be that it's an idea so just
Bishop back to thee seven not allowing
any captures on e6 and now pink to f1
getting the King to a safer Square why
not artificially castle
we have pink the b7 black does the same
and King to g1 as black still has a
light square bishop the king is probably
safer on g1 on a dark squared energy -
and also you don't block your bishop if
the bishop needs to retreat Knights the
f5 and now comes Luke the b1 we have
night c2 e 7 and now comes a rook to be
for pushing the Queen back we have Queen
to c6 and now Knight to g2 with ideas of
maybe going night to e3 to trade off the
Knights on f5 black pushes h5 and now
that the h5 point has become a target
Knight back to F for now just attacking
the pawn and here you could play g6 and
claim that you have a very solid
position but you have a lot of dark
square weaknesses here and on the other
hand your rooks are probably going to be
useless for the rest of the game
so instead Sula manly tries an active
move he plays f6 wanting to open up the
center ok
we have Quinta II one here adding
another defender to the e5 pawn and now
g5 and here is where things get really
really complicated so we don't gain
anything by capturing the other point
just takes the place and also there is a
threat of g4 so it's interesting why
even allowed to dis with Queen that you
want well he has a very concrete idea
he plays Knight captures on h5 he allows
g4 which is of course what Suleiman Lee
plays g4 now the rook and the bishop are
threatened and now rook captures on f5
here even says that his rooks aren't
doing all that much here and that his
pieces will be doing all the works okay
Knight captures on a5 with Bishop back
to g2 so basically even sacrifice the
exchange here with F captures on e5 with
D captures on e5 and now at just a5
pushing that to log back rope to be won
and Queen to c5 making making use of the
rooks and the open file now the F do
pawn is is pressured no threats for the
moment but Knight to f6 and now you can
see that this knight cuts off this rooks
influence and the F file also pressures
this rook attacks the bishop on d7 so
it's just a just a great piece we have
looked to g7 not allowing this to remain
a target also defending the bishop here
and Bishop to e3 now you cannot move the
Queen if you move the Queen rupee
actress and b6 is deadly so Knight
captures we have Queen captures and even
offers the trade of Queens we have Queen
captures pawn captures and now we get
this position where even is still down
the exchange but his knight on f6 is
just just a beautiful piece so Bishop to
pay for going after the weak C DuPont
and now look the c1 for the moment this
rook is forced to be a very passive rook
but you know if you maybe manage to get
your King over to d2 or maybe if you can
defend it some some different way then
you can activate the rook and here we
have b5 by black so now it's a very it's
very tricky position so you might even
want to pause the video and try to
figure out what you would play here with
white I'm just gonna give you a couple
of seconds it's just so we get the feel
of the position
so for those of you who found efore
congratulations on having an you know
just just great feeling for the position
as you do need to open up this bishops
diagonal if you want to if you want to
be able to counter blacks to looks so
efore we have d4 of course not allowing
this and now c captures on d4 so as
white no longer defends the be for
square now black takes this opportunity
to try and create a passport on the
Queen side with a capture say captures
now b3 might be an idea with Bishop to
f1 pressuring the the pawn here and the
b3 now would be would be too early if b3
now it's just too easy to counter it
captures captures and now Roxy for you
attack the bishop after the bishop is
defended you just check the King and put
a rule behind the passed pawn so it will
not be all that all that difficult to
defend against the passed pawns
so we have looked the c8 defending the
c4 pawn and now rook the b1 offering you
you kept from my CD point I'm gonna
capture this pawn with check and even
this guy here because it's gonna be
attacked twice so C 3 and sorry not C 3
b3
now finally creating the passed pawn but
sorry G doesn't trade he goes c3 he
doesn't want to give this rook in any or
open files that he doesn't have to
so kink the b6 and now h5 now this point
is starting to march forward
we have brushed back the b5 adding a
defender to the c4 pawn now the rope and
see it can move and now h6 we have
looked a seven and now h7 all the way we
look to h8 and here comes the Bishop to
e2 putting pressure on the g4 pawns so
if you eliminate that you can start
pushing the jeep on as well and here you
could take the the way out and and give
back the rook with rook captures Knight
captures and rook captures to just get
rid of that but it's hard hard to decide
if you're actually able to play this
because after Bishop captures energy for
there are so many points for white white
is up two pawns and after roof to g7 you
cannot allow to move the bishop and
allow captures captures you have to play
Bishop to f3 and now it's just just a
messy position if rook captures our King
goes
- then you can put d5 or if black goes
rook to a7 then he can go rook to a2 and
then to C 2 if black found all of this
then yes this would be excellent for
black but it's hard to find all this
when all of this is on the board so
black went to look to a - immediately
and okay now the bishop is under attack
Bishop captures an g4 and now look the
c2 black goes after the c3 pawn or maybe
black just wasn't interested in the draw
he's a very accomplished young chess
player he wants to take down even we
have the short captures on e6 and now b2
now the thread is grouped as a c1 check
which would just win the game for black
but here even plays rook captures and b2
he gives up a whole rook we have rook
after son b2 and now Bishop the g8 so he
gives up a whole room and then he traps
so I'm on his rook on h8 really just
crazy stuff we've roped the c2 now going
after the c3 pawn Knight to d5 check and
then now King to a5 hoping to get the
King all the way here to get rid of the
c3 pawn we have e 6 now charge starts
pushing the passed pawn bishop the c6
with East 17 taif or we have Knight b6
check with King 2b 3 and now d5 even
there was also the possibility of just
capturing and c4 but even is waiting
with this move for example after King
captures now you push d5 Bishop e8 now
you go 96 attack the bishop bishop moves
and now you play Knight to a5 but it's
it's not easy to find all of this now of
course if you capture you just under
both the the de pawns and you create a
lot of pass pawn so this would be
completely winning for white but even
went with d5 first and okay brush up the
b5 and only now these six now you're
preparing to push up on all the way to
d7 so you have to stop this we have
looked at e2 and now only now Knight
captures on c4 so the bishop can never
capture this as you have to keep an eye
on the light squares you have to keep an
eye on I ate at all times
Ruby one check getting the work out of
harm's way King f2 and now King captures
on c3 finally with Knights the a3 and
now Bishop the EA black just has the
keep control of all of the light squares
here finally 'if I've by frottage and
here we have King 2d for King daddy for
as like I said it's a very complicated
position the engines will give King
Tubby for as a much more resilient move
but it's still not enough so you know it
doesn't really matter what what the
engine says point is you will not be
even trying to save your knight here the
winning idea is just marcher King all
the way to g7 and pick up the roof
that's that's how you do it
kingi - first you attack the rook Bishop
h5 check and now you gain a temple King
III Bishop goes back King to f4 and now
whatever whatever black does you're just
gonna go all the way here
pick up the rook and that's it or you
know black and try to follow you King
here but then the knight is introduced
back into the game so no problems there
but okay now after a 5 we have King to
d4 by black and now comes a 6 by even we
have Quinta a 5 and here what do you
play here again it's a very tricky
position
feel free to pause the video and try to
try to figure out how to win this with
white so for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on being an
excellent butcher of pawns and on the
seventh rank and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
it's d7 but it requires a lot of
calculation black has to give up the
rook because the bishop has to have
constant control of the e8 square now
Knight c4 check King moves and the now
comes Knight to b6 now black doesn't
have time you have to capture you have
to move the bishop Bishop to b5 and now
comes Knight to d5 with check and here's
a problem you don't get a chance to
capture the night because then you fake
8b8 square for the pawn and if instead
of the ship to c6 you go Bishop to b5 or
something like that then Knight to d5
again it's very strong but now the
bishop will be under attack as well King
g6 now comes Knight c7
attacks the bishop and you will either
lose it but well you will lose the
bishop either way because once this pawn
Queens the night also covers the 8
square
so after King to e5 d7 is completely
winning but even plays Knight to c4
check and he allows young suleiman lee a
chance to
we go out of all of this mess with King
to f6 and now there's a problem you
don't gain anything by pushing d7 now if
d7 now you can just trade everything if
d7 just Bishop captures and it's not a
problem
each chapter skin captures an a7 and
everything is nicely protected so the
moments to push d7 is has passed with g4
by even now and rook to d5 now not
allowing anything to cross the v rank
and here even probably so that it
doesn't work here anymore but he pushed
the d7 and nevertheless so once again
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the only good defensive
resource for black while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who found King captures on e7
congratulations that's the correct way
to go because here you don't really have
anything if if pawn captures you can
bring the Queen into the game it's not a
problem King just captures and there
will be no problems in stopping and then
now this here pony you cannot move the
bishop because then you allowed the rook
into the game and it's just a nice a
nice draw game for black there's still a
lot of complications here although it is
the way to go and on the other hand if
after King cappers you go Knight b6 you
attack the rook still Rudy to check you
will move the King King III not just
Bishop captures on b7 you say okay have
your rook I'm just gonna pick up all the
points here so let's say King character
Sundy - Bishop captures and now there's
nothing to do here is Bishop captures
team captures you will pick up this guy
and it's just a draw King III or
whatever rock a person h7 easily drawn
game but after d7 for some reason so
Emily did not play King captures he
played Ruby characters on d7 like we
discussed in the previous lines where
you have to trade the roof so the bishop
has control of d8 square but if the King
captured the King would also have
control of the eight square so there's
also that so even played pawn captures
on b7 we have Bishop captures on d7 but
now Knight the b6 comes and here's a
problem that well we also had this
similar position in other other
calculations because if you move it
for example if you play something like
Bishop to c6 the same idea applies just
Knight to d5 check King g7 and now
Knight to the c7 you push the pawn you
win the bishop and that's it
so there's no way for the King to
approach the e8 square anymore so here
after Knight to be six it's really manly
played team captures on e7 but now feel
free to pause the video for the last
time and calculate everything all the
way to a win for white because it Yuma
you know it must be done so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations on being such a you know
precise calculator and for those who
just want to enjoy the show it's nice
capture Sun d7 King captures and King to
g3 you now have to realize that this is
a winning endgame for white you might
think yeah but black just goes here
picks up the rook and gives up the rook
for Bishop and pawn well yes but if you
calculated all the way to the end you
you know you you're able to win all the
important stampede you know gain
opposition of you know with your king so
King to e7 was played King to h4 now
comes King f6 and now pink to h5 and it
was in this position that I didn't saw a
manly resigned to the game because now
even if you play it out you will see
that after King g7 you get in g5 now you
have to trade here rook captures Bishop
captures King captures and now King to
f6 King to g8 and now you're clicking g6
and you have the opposition you're
winning this easily King h8 you're gonna
play g5 King moves you're just gonna
play King page six King moves g6 King
moves and g7 and now finally the black
King has the mole King of 7 here and now
you just Queen the pawn so that's why
you need to study the end games and know
your general endgame is that that you
that might just you know allow you to
spend the last time in calculating an
endgame or if you if you're just able to
calculate all the way to the end and
then that will also work but yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it really
really just amazing stuff we should all
thank nappa for pointing it out and I
blurred the position here so it doesn't
spoil it for you
the crazy position although it's the one
I'm using in the thumbnail so I guess
you guys have already seen it but yeah
once again I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Dobrev Caraga for
several doe Ally jr. rollin open Alan
Rosenberg and William McKay for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous video serie
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon probably with a Michael
Tyler game as by the time I'm done
making this video this channel probably
already hit five five hundred thousand
subscribers so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent festivity